[MUSIC PLAYING]
When I first arrived at MIT
as a freshman two years ago,
my FPOP counselor suggested
I joined this club called,
Dance Troupe.
I'd never danced
before, but I figured
I would give it a
try for one semester.
I mean, after all, that's
what P and R is for, right?
Today, I'm a member of
Ridonkulous and Asian Dance
Team.
And I'm an officer and
choreographer for Dance Troupe.
It's a lot, for sure,
but it's so, so worth it.
Dance has helped me become
more confident and comfortable
in my own body, and the
people are just the best.
We tease each other and
joke with each other,
but at the end of the day, these
guys have my back in anything.
I've been a part of this family
for the first half of my MIT
career, and I'm so, so excited
to see what happens next.